Not today.
Your new World Order jackboot.
Sooner or later, there'll be raiders.
They'll come at night, quiet and armed.
My name's Frank. Call
Joel
Here’s the thing Frank
If I feed you,
then every bum you talk to about
it is going to show up here
looking for a free lunch.
And this is not an Arby's.
We'll be fine.
Arbys
didn’t have free lunch it was a restaurant.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my full
Last of Us
Episode 3 Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're also doing a giveaway
for HBO Max Subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the trailer on the video careful
for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far.
If you haven't caught up
with the episodes yet,
but you're starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage,
it seems like the first scene
is part of many flashbacks
in the episode to explain Bill's backstory
and who Frank was to him.
We even see how he met
Frank in the flashbacks
when he gets stuck in one of Bill's traps.
Bill is played by Nick Offerman,
who most of you will recognize.
He's a huge character.
Early in the first game.
Who knows? Joel in tests.
They're not best friends
or anything like that.
He just worked with them through their
smuggling operation in the past.
In a lot of the episode,
looks like it's meant to show you
what life is like for people
living outside of the quarantine zones.
Like there is life outside the quarantine
zones, but it gets way, way crazier.
There is virtually no law at all.
Like during the trailer.
In the flashbacks, Joel tells them,
You better be ready
because raiders are going to come.
And it seems like Bill's like,
No, don't worry about it.
I have this barbed wire fence.
I have all these traps.
I'll be totally fine.
It turns out things are not fine.
You keep babysitting long enough,
and eventually it's going to blow up
buildings.
We see all the other trailer footage
with raiders coming for him
and them getting this giant firefight.
But the whole idea is that he knows Joel
and Tess, which is why in the flashbacks,
when it seems like he gets injured,
he tells Frank to call Joel Lay,
call him for help,
implying that Joel and test
have helped him
out of some jams in the past.
In the scene here,
he just looking at a group of other
survivors passing through his town
on his CCTV cameras being very removed
from what's happening outside.
Like they want to show you that
he keeps this very strict
barrier between him and other people.
And it's one of the reasons
why he's been able
to survive outside of the quarantine.
Those living by himself, because at least
up until the point when he meets
Frank, he has been living by himself,
which is absolutely crazy.
Like, you have to be a mad man
to want to live on your own
in the apocalypse in an area like this.
But a lot of the flashbacks
are meant to show you
how Bill has been able to survive for this
long in a part of his personality,
like his deep mistrust of the government
and everyone else just in general.
But he also has a hard core fort built
in this town,
like you see barbed wire
fence around this small area here.
But he also has traps everywhere.
Frank gets stuck in one of them
in the flashbacks.
He has a bunch of weapons
in one of the other
really clever things that he does that
Joel remarks on in the game
is that he uses the infected
that roam the area just like random
infected is a sort of natural barrier
that are effective against other rogue
groups that want to take his stuff low.
Just the fact
that there are a lot of infected
roaming around in the area outside
the quarantine zone is a natural deterrent
to people looking to poke around the area.
And a lot of the scenes,
especially the flashbacks with the Raiders
telling us Bill and Frank's
backstory is meant to foreshadow
a lot of the trouble that Ellie and Joel
were going to encounter on their journey
across the rest of the United States.
That's why, even though it's a flashback,
it seems like when Joel is telling him
you need to watch out,
raiders are going to come, they end.
It is such an ominous way
because it's also going to be happening
to Joe and Lee in the future.
They're a couple more important
antagonistic groups
they run into on their way
across the United States.
The hunters are one of the bigger groups.
They've changed some of their backstory
for the TV show,
but we've seen some of them
in the trailers.
They're not going to be in episode three.
They're from another episode
in the future.
But like I said, it
just meant to show you what life is like
for people
living outside the quarantine zones,
because Bill is just one of many doing
that.
Tommy is another example
that Joel's brother living in Wyoming
in a settlement outside
of one of the regular quarantine zones.
We saw some of that in the earlier
trailers, too.
The difference
between Tommy and Bill, though,
is that Tommy just way more well-adjusted.
The reason why Joe in L.A.
go to Bill's during the trailer
is because they're looking for a car
that will get them
the rest of the way to Wyoming to check on
Tommy Joel's brother, because he's worried
about what happened to him.
Remember, during episode one,
he was trying to contact him,
but it'd been three weeks
since he'd heard back from him.
So he's just worried
that something happened.
And he also still needs to get her
the rest of the way to Salt Lake City,
Utah, to the rest of the fireflies
who might be able to create a vaccine
for the fungus. Here's where we get to
some of the differences from the game.
So one of the things
the show has been doing
the past couple of episodes
you probably noticed,
is that they are following the game
pretty closely,
but they change a couple of minor
things in.
They've expanded a bunch
on some of the scenes.
All this backstory with Bill
and Frank is one of those things
that they're expanding on.
Like you just meet Bill during the games
and you hear about Frank in past tense.
I think they beefed up their backstory
and cast a version of Frank on the show
just to show you in present day
how Bill got to be the way that he is.
Just explain his character
a little bit more.
Because in present day
when Joe and Ellie visit him
and then they leave to go
on their separate way,
one of the things that he tells Joe,
like one of his pieces of advice,
is not to love anyone
because caring for people
will only get you killed,
which is kind of
where Joel is at emotionally.
At the end of episode two,
after he watch Tense Die,
the second person that he loved.
It is a way of showing you
how far Joel has to go inside emotionally
before he starts to care about Ellie.
Genuinely,
she's a little quicker to trust him, but
that's just because she's so vulnerable
the way that she exists right now.
So she's still very capable.
She understands the fungus,
she understands the infected,
but she's still so dependent upon Joel
to get her the rest of the way.
She kind of has to trust him to survive.
Whereas Joel was ready to bail on her
at the drop of a hat
at the end of episode two.
Tess had to talk him into it
like, No, no, no, you have to do this.
You have to make things right.
And he barely agreed.
Love all the jokes between Bill
and Frank in the flashbacks.
Big shout out to Arby's.
I wonder if they had to pay for that.
Probably not.
The fact that he skips on Arby's
never giving away free lunches in the past
is just to show you that
when he finds Frank,
he's got a little nutters in the head.
Like I said,
you have to be a little bit crazy
to want to live outside
the quarantine zones by yourself.
Frank is meant to be another survivor
that stumbles into his trap.
It just winds up softening Bill's
heart like you see him in the flashback
when he's talking to Joe, he looks like
he's wearing pants that are clean.
He's got a clean shirt
on. He looks like he's shaved his beard.
Whereas the first time that he meets
Frank earlier in the timeline,
it seems like he hasn't
taken a shower in like a year.
And it just seems like
what happens in the flashbacks
is that at some point
Joel and Tess visited him
as part of their smuggling operation
and trading supplies,
warned him about Raiders
and he was kind of nonchalant about it.
Eventually the Raiders came.
They had a big firefight,
and that's how Frank wound up dying.
This footage of Ellie
walking around the house
looking at the guns is in Bill's house.
And it seems like based on this arc
that they're presenting in the flashbacks
here in present day, when Joe and Ellie
find Bill, he's kind of devolve back
to a version of himself that's a little
more like he was before he met Frank.
But remember, the big mission in episode
three is them finding a car that works,
or at least fixing a car that will work,
that will get them the rest of the way.
One of the other
big things from the games, too,
is that they do encounter a blunder
during the missions at Bill's place.
Ellie referenced that during episode two,
when she's like, What about walkers?
That through spore bombs at you,
but because they're not doing spores
during season one, we'll see if they do
wind up doing the blow
to her from the games
or if these point have changed that
a little bit.
There were a couple of big things
that they changed during episode two,
like when they arrive at the city center,
they're at the Capitol building
when Tess reveals
that she's been bitten
and sacrifices herself
so that Joel and Ellie
can get away in the game.
It was just a group of federal,
like a couple federal soldiers
that came to kill her
to try and capture them
because they learned about the guard
that Joel had killed during episode one.
I think the version of the show
wound up being better, like
I think it was better
having the infected come
than just being
a couple of federal soldiers.
Some of you also spotted
that one of the dead
fireflies at the end of the episode
here on the floor was Neil Druckmann,
the original creator of The Last of Us.
He's featured in a lot of the
behind the scenes footage, too.
Speaking of Neil Druckmann in the game,
there's been a lot of questions
about how they're going to plot the show
because Season one is supposed to cover
pretty much
all of the events of the first game,
meaning that
they do the events of the second game.
They bring that up over season
two and season three.
So if they want to go to a season four
and beyond, they basically have to either
write more story like Neil Druckmann
would have to create more story for them,
or they have to make The Last of Us 3.
And Neil Druckmann actually teased earlier
a couple of weeks ago
that there was more story to tell.
Naughty Dog hasn't officially announced
that they're making Last of Us 3,
but it sounds like they're thinking
about it.
It's kind of the same problem that House
of the Dragon and Game of Thrones
had because there's been all this talk
about them doing the kit Harington Jon
Snow series after the events of the main
series Game of Thrones,
which was supposed to adapt pretty much
all the events of the original novels
and George R.R.
Martin hasn't written any canon material
that takes place after the events of
what will be a Dream of Spring,
which is supposed to be
the events of Game of Thrones
Season eight.
But in the case of House of the Dragon,
Game of Thrones, George R.R.
Martin is way more involved
with the creation.
A lot of the spinoffs,
the prequels in the sequels.
So he's made it sound like he's going
to create more cannon material himself
set after the events of Game of Thrones
for them to base this Jon Snow's sequel on
or any other potential sequels.
So right now
I'm assuming that Neil Druckmann
would at least do something like that
because The Last of Us 2
doesn't really feel like a final ending
for a lot of the characters.
It'd be like them stopping Game of Thrones
at the end of season two.
But if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My For Last of Us Episode 3 video
we'll post Sunday after they release it.
Supposedly, James
Gunn is also going to announce his DC
Phase one slate of movies this week.
So whatever he winds up announcing
whenever trailers
wind up dropping,
of course I'll do videos for that.
We also have a bunch of Super Bowl
trailers coming in a couple of weeks.
So there's going to be
a lot of really big stuff coming up.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Congratulations. Pair of Droid.
You're the giveaway winner from my last
Last of Us episode video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for My Fool
Last of Us Episode 2 Video
and Easter Eggs and click here
for All My Last of Us Videos.
Thank you so much for watching.